joining us now Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
Sonora and policy group vice-president
Daniel Hoffman number one Gina Haskell
is an American Hero
and those that have smeared and
slandered her we don't get the courier
without KSM be waterboarded and we don't
get bin Laden
so this slander has to stop she would be
a great CIA director mr. Hoffman I
couldn't agree more I served with Gina
for many years I think very highly of
her she's got a tremendously high level
of intellectual honesty and integrity
and dedication to our mission the people
at the agency think the world of her
she's had all the experience and listen
for the past 15 months she's been deputy
director that's a tremendous audition
for this administration they know what
they're getting we do too
she's the right choice and I just hope
that the Congress does the right thing
and confirms her dr. Gork I know ed
Henry just reported that maybe the
president wants to throw a bone to our
allies the one thing people don't seem
to understand about President Trump he
keeps his promises he keeps them all I
expect I look I don't have a crystal
ball
I have no insight my guess he pulls us
out of that horrific deal and John
Kerry's conduct has been despicable and
disgusting and we had two lawyers
tonight say he violated the Logan Act
yeah this is I know it's shocking for
most people that this is a politician
who keeps his promises but that is
Donald Trump he's wanted to kill the
Iran deal for two years now I expect
there's not going to be any pulled
punches tomorrow we've had basically
eight years under Obama of what treating
our enemies
like Iran his friends bribery of
dictators and sure sure it was very easy
for eight years our enemies were treated
as friends like Iran given boatloads of
cash and our friends like Israel were
treated as enemies that has all stopped
we're moving the embassy to Jerusalem
we're recognizing it as the capital of
the eternal State of Israel and the Iran
deal has to be killed it has to be shot
in the head because it is bad for
America it's bad for the world and it's
bad for our friends well said
you know with all the talk about foreign
interference and elections we
all forget Daniel Hoffman we all forget
that Obama tried to work hard to defeat
Benjamin Netanyahu the person with more
moral clarity with more strength on the
world stage than any other leader
besides now Donald Trump well yeah and
let me just add one more point about the
Iran deal look it's a highly flawed deal
as we all know Iran is technically
complying with the deal but the
challenge for our administration is
having been left with this look at the
intelligence look what we learned last
week from Prime Minister Netanyahu
absolutely that's and that's the end the
challenge though is we don't the other
signatories to the deal they don't agree
with us Russia and China are not going
to support us Russia's building a
nuclear power plant in bushier the the
frame should have major economic
interest this is going to be a real
diplomatic challenge for our
administration I would just highlight as
well a challenge about Iran's community
collect the intelligence on Iran's
intentions if we do terminate the deal a
little rock the man try to make it clear
that we are going down how we would
launch attacks in the event that Iran
does restore little Rocketman rich cave